One of the classic definitions of
mindfulness is that it helps us not
cling to what's pleasant and not condemn
what is unpleasant.
So an example would be if you're driving
in New York City and someone cuts you
off,
you know,
that's unpleasant and one would
instinctively have an angry response.
But that's happening all the time.
And if you have an angry response too
often,
then you become a nightmare yourself.
So what mindfulness is teaching is that
the stimulus,
which is someone cutting you off,
is different.
It's distinct from your emotional
reaction to that thing.
So someone could cut you off,
you could feel the anger,
but you don't have to act on the anger.
So instead of being driven by your
reactions,
there's a little bit of a of room where
you can choose to be a different kind of
person.
So mindfulness basically helps us
tolerate,
uh,
the,
the aspects of the external world and
the internal world that otherwise are
hard to face.
There are basically two kinds of
meditation.
One,
which is a concentration practice.
You focus your attention on a neutral
sensation,
like the feeling of the breath coming in
and out of the nostrils or uh,
like the repetition of a sound or what's
called a mantra.
And every time the mind wanders,
whenever you notice that it's wandered,
that might be five minutes,
10 minutes later when you're lost in
thought.
But at a certain point you realize,
oh wait,
I'm not watching the breath anymore.
Then you bring your mind back to the
breath.
That's called a concentration or a one
point in practice.
And that's the,
that's the,
uh,
beginning level of mindfulness.
When you really start practicing
mindfulness,
instead of bringing the mind back every
time to a central object,
you let the attention go wherever the
mind goes.
So instead of paying attention just to
the breath or the mantra,
you pay attention to sounds.
You pay attention to thoughts,
you pay attention to feelings,
you pay attention to memories.
You pay attention to worries,
to anxieties,
to anger,
to joy.
You pay attention to whatever passes
through your mind moment to moment.
And then what you start to see is that
oh,
everything is changing all the time.
And uh,
uh,
you learn to pay attention more to
process then to content.
It's really only in the past 50,
60 years that the medical establishment
has been exposed at all to what
mindfulness is.
And for 20,
30 of those years,
it was like just a new age thing.
It was on the periphery and only through
the work of,
uh,
a couple of people like John Kabat Zinn,
has mindfulness come into the medical
establishment.
And there are a lot of studies that are
being done now,
um,
that are showing the benefit of
mindfulness for all kinds of,
uh,
conditions.
And some old colleagues of mine,
uh,
have done some very good work showing
that the steady practice of mindfulness
light up areas of the brain that have to
do with modulating emotional reactivity.
Um,
so I think there's beginning evidence
that the,
the brain is plastic more plastic than
we initially thought.
And that the,
you know,
what,
what you feed into the brain actually
changes the architecture of the brain so
that it's possible to promote,
to develop the areas of the brain that
are there,
uh,
for kindness,
you know,
for altruistic feeling.
Uh,
and for the regulation of difficult
emotions.